oui les navaloshi vous nous avez rejoint
euh c'est vrai que ces attaques sont une
piqûre de rappel les Russes peuvent
frapper fort à tout moment partout en
Ukraine et nabial disait dans ce sujet
là cette fois Poutine assume avoir
frappé hein oui c'est vrai que c'est la
première fois qu'on a de cette façon là
aussi assumer le rapport de cause à
conséquence entre les destructions en
Ukraine bien qu'il ne parle toujours pas
de pertes civile il parle pas du tout
des morts et des blessés de ses frappes
mais en tout cas il parle des
destructions et la cause qui est
directement la Russie c'est-à-dire que
la Russie assume pour la première fois
aussi ouvertement le fait d'avoir frappé
une infrastructure énergétique
c'est-à-dire une infrastructure civile
jusqu'à présent à partir du de du moment
où le président ukrainien voit le dîner
Zelinski a lancé sa contre-offensive le
1er septembre dans dans le nord du pays
dans la région de kerkiff il y avait
cette petite musique montante cette
rhétorique montante de la propagande
russe qui disait voilà jusqu'à présent
on a toujours été dans la retenue dans
cette guerre on y allait avec le dos de
la cuillère épargnant les civils c'est
même ce terme d'épargner les civils qui
étaient prononcé papa par la télévision
russe alors même qu'on se souvient
d'épisode comme la guerre de kramator
parce qu'avec une cinquantaine de morts
comme même bout de chat comme voilà les
frappes qui ont fait tant de victimes en
Ukraine mais jusqu'à présent les rues
sont toujours dit soit ce n'est pas nous
soit c'est un fake news vous souvenez le
centre commercial à cremenciu par
exemple nous on a visé une base
militaire et ce sont les Ukrainiens
ensuite qui ont inventé les victimes
civiles c'était ça que disait les Russes
or le 15 septembre suite à la
contre-offensive du président volody
merzelinski il y avait déjà cette
rhétorique à la télévision russe qui
disait voilà maintenant on va devoir
riposter à ce qui était toujours
présenté en commun une attaque des
Ukrainiens donc cette position défensive
de la Russie on ne peut plus retenir il
faut frapper l'infrastructure
ukrainienne ce qu'il y a de nouveau
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est Vladimir
Poutine qui le dit et non plus seulement
les propagandistes de la télévision
russe c'est que ensuite la télévision
russe elle elle développe cette ce
message en montrant en fait telle
centrale électrique en faisant des
chroniques si vous voulez traiter
rencontre électrique à telle capacité et
avec ces destructions tant de
régions temps de ville telle surface va
être privée d'électricité donc c'est
vraiment en fait un message finalement
un message de terreur aussi qui envoyait
à l'Ukraine de dire voilà la Russie à
cette capacité de frappe elle peut vous
priver de chauffage cet hiver elle peut
vous priver d'électricité on a la
capacité de mettre toute l'Ukraine hors
tension et donc en fait pour la première
fois c'est vraiment une menace envers
non seulement l'état ukrainien mais les
civils Ukrainiens qui est proféré au
plus haut sommet de l'Etat russe par
Vladimir Poutine lui-même merci Elena le
président